si la parole à monsieur joël billard
pour le groupe union pour un mouvement
populaire
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le ministre de
l'intérieur monsieur le ministre dans la
nuit du 13 au 14 juillet la ville de
bonneval dont je fus maire a été le
théâtre de dégradations et
d'affrontements entre les forces de
l'ordre et une bande composée d'une
trentaine d'individus mineurs et majeurs
fortement alcoolisé ces individus s'en
sont pris à une vitrine puis la d'evry
d'habitation les gendarmes en patrouille
ont tenté de s'interposer et de ramener
le calme sortis de leur voiture ils ont
été roués de coups résultat de
l'opération trois gendarmes blessés et
des dégradations sérieuse dans ma ville
il faut ajouter qu'un gendarme
interpellant un mineur se voit le plus
souvent taxé de brutalité ou de
maltraitance par les parents du mineur
monsieur le ministre
cette situation est proprement
inadmissible et inacceptable
s'attaquer aux forces de l'ordre c'est
le début d'anarchie et pour reprendre
l'expression célèbre général de gaulle
c'est la chienlit en effet qu attendent
d'une nation dont certains
ressortissants brûlent le drapeau
français siph cif notre hymne national
siph le président de la république et ce
en toute impunité
et je ne vous parle pas de l'attitude
des gens du voyage peut-être serait-il
bon dans un premier temps que les
parents des dix mineurs soient
sanctionnés par exemple par la
suspension provisoire des allocations
familiales qui servent à élever les
enfants qui servent à élever les enfants
et non pas à les mettre dans la rue de
plus ayant pris un arrêté municipal pour
interdire la circulation des mineurs non
accompagnés sur l'ensemble du territoire
de la commune à partir de 22 heures il
m'a été demandé par les services de
l'état de le modifier en y apportant de
la souplesse demande incomprise et
rejeté par la population et les élus je
terminerai mon propos en soulignant
l'action courageuse des forces de
l'ordre ainsi que cette désintéresser
des cinq cent mille vies ne valent que
sont les élus de la république attendant
de votre part un soutien
et un message de fermeté voici monsieur
le ministre la situation intolérable que
je voulais vous exposez
merci la parole à madame najat vallaud
belkacem ministre et droits des femmes
porte parole du gouvernement
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs de succès d'atr
permettez-moi d'excuser l'absence de
manuel valls qui est actuellement retenu
en lituanie pour un conseil justice et
affaires intérieures
revenons donc sur la sphère que vous
évoquez c'est vrai que votre commune a
été le théâtre d'une agression le 14
juillet dernier de trois gendarmes qui
effectué une patrouille de sécurisation
qui ont été victimes de quelques jeunes
en état d'ébriété vous l'avez rappelé
pour la plupart avant d'en venir à ce
qui a été mise en oeuvre sur cette
affaire je voudrais d'abord commencé par
remercier et féliciter l'ensemble des
policiers des gendarmes des pompiers qui
sur un week-end aussi chargé comme on le
sait comme celui du 14 juillet ont un
peu partout en france fait en sorte que
les festivités se déroulent dans les
meilleures conditions mais s'agissant de
l'incident que vous évoquez d'abord vous
savez que trois personnes ont été
interpellées et que ces personnes
passeront au tribunal de chartres cet
après midi en comparution immédiate
ensuite pour le reste de votre
interrogation monsieur le sénateur je
veux vous redire à quel point le droit à
la sécurité est un droit qui est
aujourd'hui promu et défendues par
l'ensemble du gouvernement à commencer
par le ministre de l'intérieur quel que
soit le territoire d'ailleurs dans
lequel on vit en milieu urbain
périurbain comment rural et c'est vrai
que si l'effort portant en particulier
sur les zones de sécurité prioritaire le
milieu rural n'est aucunement négliger
quand je regarde le département d'eure
et loir le vôtre les résultats sont même
plutôt encourageant j note par exemple
que les atteintes volontaires à
l'intégrité physique les violences aux
personnes sont en baisse de 10% au
premier semestre 2013 même si on doit
encore faire mieux pour prévenir les
violences au sein des familles les
cambriolages qui étaient en forte
augmentation en 2012 sont aujourd'hui
quasiment maîtrisé d'autres chiffres
viennent confirmer tout cela quant à vos
deux interrogations monsieur le sénateur
sur l'arrêté couvre feu que vous avez
voulu prendre cécile et l'action des
élus en matière d'insécurité est
importante elle doit quand même
s'inscrire dans le cadre des lois et
donc il est naturel que les préfets
exercent un contrôle de légalité quand
les mesures que vous prenez entre en
contradiction avec ce qui a été voté par
le législateur c'est ce qui s'est passé
les préfets ont un rôle de conseil au
maire et le gouvernement les conforte
totalement en ce sens quant à la
question des parents et de leurs
responsabilités quant aux agissements de
leurs enfants je vous rappelle que nous
prenons ici une responsabilité
individuelle est pas une responsabilité
collective je vous remercie